[Musique]
la havane capitale de l'île de cuba
chaque année trois millions de visiteurs
foulent les pavés du malecon la
promenade mythique du front de mer
et c'est ici que depuis le mois d'août
flotte le symbole d'une nouvelle ère le
drapeau américain
l'ambassade a rouvert après 54 ans de
froid diplomatique entre cuba les états
unis et pour ie vanille trente deux ans
c'est une benne il est propriétaire
d'une casse sa pâle qui coule à une
maison d'hôtes qu'il appelle la maison
blanche n'a été on va terminer cette
chambre depuis le rapprochement
elle affiche complet grâce à ses
nouveaux clients les touristes
américains
[Musique]
yann danis à te va comme ça c'est
parfait au pied d'immeubles jane et son
ami il arrive tout juste de washington
pour deux jours
bonjour enchanté vous avez fait bon
voyage
[Musique]
officiellement il est encore interdit
pour les américains de venir faire du
tourisme à cuba
mais depuis le dégel washington commence
à accorder des dérogations
en attendant de changer sa loi vient
voir c'est parfait c'est encore plus
beau que sur les photos
jane et son ami sont donc venus profiter
de l'île interdite avant que leurs
compatriotes de vienne en basse c'est le
meilleur moment pour venir à cuba
car dans deux ans il sera certainement
comme le costa rica ou porto rico ce
sera plein d'américains ce n'est pas si
les clés de la maison
cuba à temps 300 mille américains par an
dans les années à venir il faut dire que
la floride n'est qu'à 160 km une heure
de vol la havane est la destination
idéale pour se dépayser un week end
regardez ça c'est le mois d'octobre
tout ce qui est en verre ce sont les
réservations de touristes américains
il y en a une vingtaine we lire la bien
vains et avons vous en aviez combien
avant grosjean n'avait que quatre par
mois
giovanni gagne environ 800 dollars par
mois 40 fois le salaire moyen à cuba
cette petite fortune il la doit à airbnb
le géant américain de la location entre
particuliers vient de s'implanter sur
l'île communiste
mais l'ouverture at elle vraiment
métamorphosé le pays
pas si sûr
[Musique]
dans les années 50 cuba et le las vegas
des caraïbes
les américains y vont pour les plages
mais aussi pour ses casinos ils
investissent volontiers dans ce pays
sauf qu'en 1959 le dictateur batista est
renversé par un certain fidel castro et
la révolution cubaine sait mener et
gagner des batailles
le jeune révolutionnaire nationalise les
entreprises et les hôtels américains
washington décrète alors l'embargo
économique pendant 50 ans cuba et les
etats-unis seront des ennemis jurés
mais en décembre 2014
les relations diplomatiques sont
rétablis et en mars dernier obama rend
visite à raul castro le président du
pays
quelques jours plus tard
autre symbole historique les rolling
stones donne un gigantesque concert à la
havane devant quelque 500 mille
personnes
[Musique]
plus que jamais cette destination est à
la mode
elle attire sur ses plages de rêve 3
millions de touristes chaque année
mais que cache réellement cette
ouverture vous allez découvrir qu'elle
est surtout précieuse pour les
militaires et les dignitaires de ce
régime
il possède plus de la moitié des
chambres d'hôtel de lille et une
publique
aucun chiffre sur ce trésor non on ne
peut pas avoir de contrôle ni de
chiffres exacts sur ses activités
pendant que le pouvoir s'enrichir les
habitants eux survivent avec moins de 25
$ par mois et grâce au système d si je
prends pas le risque de mesnac trop cuts
et je ramène pas d'argent la maison et
gare à ceux qui osent critiquer le clan
castro comme danilo un jeune graffeur
incarcéré depuis dix mois
sa mère maria victoria craint pour sa
vie
si on le retrouve mort un matin on ne
saura jamais la vérité
certains opposants disparaissent dans
des conditions très trouble est mort
quand nous pouvons confirmer qu'il n'a
pas eu d'accident nous avons le droit de
savoir comment ils sont morts réforme en
trompe-l'oeil répression et propagande
bienvenue à cuba à l'heure de la grande
illusion
[Musique]
avec ses façades défraîchies ses rues
chargées d'histoire et ses vieilles
voitures américaines
la havane aujourd'hui est une
destination à la mode pour les touristes
du monde entier
dans cet immeuble un groupe de français
originaire de nancy est passionnée de
salsa
ils sont venus se perfectionner sous le
regard de leurs professeurs car minda
même s'ils ont commencé il ya peu de
temps avec moi ils ont des bases et là
on va je suis conforté les bases qu'ils
ont et les rendre un petit peu plus à
l'aise dans leur danse donc voilà je les
confie aux mains de professeurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si ce petit groupe est venu là ce n'est
pas seulement pour danser c'est aussi
pour découvrir cette île si intrigante
c'est la première fois que benoît qui
tient un salon de coiffure à nancy vient
à cuba et il vit un véritable voyage
dans le temps qui passe et hyper super
important futures au niveau des
bâtiments séparé que tu remarques un
petit peu les façades a coûté mur qu'on
peut y trouver c'est vachement beaucoup
y ait des richesses bouchées double
depuis leur arrivée benoît carmina et
les autres ont pris leurs habitudes
lorsqu'il s'agit de se déplacer pour
visiter la ville de ce qui se passe on
va pousser la voiture il va falloir
pousser
ça c'est unique arrive avec les
[Rires]
avec l'embargo imposé sur cuba les
pièces de rechange sont rares c'est donc
un petit miracle si ces voitures qui ont
plus de 60 ans rôle temps encore
direction le fort de la havane qui
surplombe la baie avec une vue
imprenable sur la ville
magnifique les français sont séduits par
le spectacle et les cubains par thaïs
balisant les ont pas beaucoup de blonde
alors forcément dès qu'ils envoient une
balle bien plus salée en forme quoi
c'est pas comme si on n'était pas du
tout en chair donc ils n'aiment pas les
cubains et plus on et enchaîne avec
l'izoard
quant à elle me plaisent beaucoup
pourquoi parce qu'elles sont magnifiques
[Musique]
le dernier voyage à cuba de carmine
dallas prof de salsa remonte à il ya
moins d'un an
elle n'en revient pas de voir autant
d'affluence touristique aujourd'hui
là il ya un bateau de croisière ça ne
soyez jamais avant dans la valise
américaine qui arrive beaucoup de
touristes européens aussi
bien avant que ça change c'est le cvo le
la phrase qu'on entend beaucoup je
connais avant que ça change
[Musique]
les français ont trouvé leur petit coin
de paradis
loin de la foule playa délester une
plage de sable fin à seulement 30
minutes du centre de la havane
[Musique]
non je fais quand je
jeopardy caraïbes
mais cette plage ne restera peut-être
pas sauvage très longtemps benoît le
coiffeur nancéen s'inquiètent
sa première fois que commencer c'est
vrai qu'on entend pas mal parlé de
l'arrivée des américains
scheer et l'invasion des américains et
que tout va changer on va se transformer
comme avec comme à miami puis ça dommage
j'espère qu'ils vont garder c'est peu ce
côté naturel pour se désaltérer sous les
cocotiers à cuba
rien de tel que le cocktail local devenu
le plus célèbre au monde
le mojito et après l'apéro la journée se
termine toujours par un petit pas de
danse
pendant ce temps pour tous et pourtant
alors que nous on n'a pas l'habitude en
france
[Musique]
si cuba s'ouvre autant au tourisme qui
t'a enterré aujourd'hui la hache de
guerre avec son pire ennemi le satan
américain
c'est que les vacanciers rapporte gros
aux régimes communistes et à ses
dignitaires
fernando est un dissident politique
ils dénoncent la mainmise de l'état sur
le secteur du tourisme
il nous emmène au parquet sentra la
place la plus visitée de la ville pour
leur séjour les étrangers ont le choix
entre le télégraphe au ling la terra ou
le plaza en apparence trois hôtels
indépendants mais en réalité ils ont
tous le même propriétaire
ces deux là sont à l'état oui les deux
appartiennent à l'état et celui-là
appartient à une entreprise de l'état
une qui possède plusieurs hôtels dans la
vieille ville de la havane
nous pénétrons dans l'un d'entre eux est
à bord dont une femme de chambre ici il
ya des clients de tous les pays il y a
énormément d'américains on a des groupes
de français beaucoup de groupes de
français
malgré un confort sommaire et une
décoration des années soixante sept
chambres standard est louée 300 euros la
nuit sur l'île le régime procéderait au
moins vingt-quatre mille lits et cette
manne financière est géré directement
par le général luis alberto rodriguez
qui n'est autre que le gendre de raul
castro
les opposants critiquent d'un système
opaque et se demande où passent tout cet
argent
non on ne peut pas avoir de contrôle ni
de chiffres exacts sur ses activités les
informations qu'on a sont approximatives
et l'état compte doubler son nombre de
chambres d'ici 2020 rien qu'à la vanne
il est en train de construire trois
hôtels de luxe et ils s'octroient pour
cela les meilleurs emplacements en
expropriant les cubains comme ici sur le
malecon c'est justement ce qui arrive
aux voisins de yovani hector piovani va
ouvrir une deuxième maison d'hôtes et il
est intéressé par les vieilles portes de
la maison d'hector avant que celui ci ne
soit expropriés ses portes sont d'époque
on n'y a jamais touché
le cadre est en acajou et les portes en
cédant 6 yovanny se fournit en pièces
détachées chez hector c'est qu'à cuba
malgré l'ouverture
une chose n'a pas changé le manque de
matières premières bon je reprends
contact avec toi et on discutera du prix
dans quelques semaines la maison
d'hector va être rasé ça c'est notre
chambre avec ma femme elle va être
remplacée par un palace de 200 me
chambrent ici on va construire un hôtel
regarder je vais vous montrer la vue
panoramique de l'avenue du prado et
malecon où l'on voit le futur hôtel
c'est l'un des emplacements les plus
chers de la ville sans commentaire on
n'a pas besoin d'en dire plus hector a
demandé en échange un logement dans la
capitale et un autre ailleurs en bord de
mer
l'état y réfléchit en attendant c'est à
contrecoeur qu'il fait ses valises
évidemment que ça me fait de la peine de
laisser cette maison tout d'abord pour
des raisons sentimentales cette maison
elle était ma famille depuis les années
elle était transmise de génération en
génération
je vais être le dernier à l'occuper si
l'état exproprie sans scrupules
il a aussi lâché un peu de lest ouvrant
le marché de l'immobilier
cela fait seulement cinq ans que les
cubains ont le droit d'acheter et de
vendre leur logement
l'un des principaux boulevards le paseo
del prado est même devenu un marché
immobilier en plein air tous les samedis
des dizaines de cubains vienne qui
proposait leur appartement à la vente
les petites annonces sont inscrits sur
des pancartes en carton
[Musique]
ce jeune homme vend un appartement de
deux chambres 2 salles de bains une
salle à manger et un jardin le tout pour
environ 5500 euros appartement ou maison
maison
ok maison je vous mets la description du
junior est agent immobilier un métier
interdit pendant plus de 50 ans très
important la naissance j'ai réussi à
l'obtenir pour exercer son activité
il doit payer une taxe à l'état et pour
la boire je dois payer 20 euros par mois
tous les mois il faut je paye 20 euros
peu importe que je fasse des ventes ou
pas s'imagine si je gagne 8 euros en un
mois comment je fais pour payer la
licence à cuba 80 % des gens sont
propriétaires de leur logement pouvoir
vendre aujourd'hui c'est donc la
possibilité d'encaisser une belle somme
et d'envisager un avenir meilleur
oh oui il y en a qui ont le projet de
partir ils ont beaucoup de raisons pour
vouloir vendre
en clair ces cubains peuvent enfin
s'offrir un billet d'avion à plusieurs
centaines de dollars et refaire
peut-être leur vie à l'étranger car pour
la majorité d'entre eux l'ouverture
n'est qu'une illusion
elle ne change en rien le difficile
quotidien dans cette dictature
bonjour mes enfants rose marie est
institutrice en maternelle depuis plus
de trois ans elle ne gagne que 13
dollars par mois
vous aimez l'histoire des trois petits
cochons
pourtant le régime communiste a fait de
l'école une priorité il investit près de
13 % de son pib dans l'éducation
résultats l'île communiste à éradiquer
l'analphabétisme est long le grand
méchant nous rôder autour de la maison
des trois petits cochons et il soufflait
s'essouffler mais à côté des jolis
contes
les élèves sont endoctrinés dès le plus
jeune âge
tous les jours ils doivent chanter à la
gloire de la révolution cubaine qui peut
me réciter le beau poème que l'on
connaît tous
tu es mulemo lieu qu'on les prenne un
frein à l'ombre à ma copine tu es là
mérite à la rose marie habite à saint
augustine un quartier pauvre en
périphérie de la havane
elle occupe le rez-de-chaussée de cet
immeuble avec sa mère anna regarde
regarde et son fils ismaël
c'est mon fils qu'elle agit là il a
trois ans que l'âge tu as toi mon
travail caméra dans l'appartement
familial habite aussi carlos son oncle
mon oncle c'est celui qui met de la
musique à la maison et dans le quartier
avec ses 13 dollars de salaire par mois
rose-marie ben à remplir le frigo c'est
comme ça dans toutes les familles
cubaines qui vivent grâce aux salaires
d'état et dans le congélateur ce n'est
pas beaucoup mieux
ça c'est de la croquette de soja c'est
le plat principal
depuis 50 ans les cubains sont soumis au
rationnement regarde ça c'est la fameuse
libre et à ses pour rationné la
nourriture
oui à cuba nous avons un carnet de
rationnement par famille chez nous nous
sommes 6 nous devons vivre grâce à ce
carnet
tout est rationnée oui par mois par
exemple ce mois ci nous avons prix du
riz du sucre
quoi d'autre
de lui l'un à cela s'ajoute un peu de
haricots ou des pâtes mais les quantités
sont insuffisantes pour une famille
entière
on vous donne un peu plus de 3 kg de riz
par personne et par mois pas plus si tu
veux plus il faut payer les pistes et
sous le manteau et ses trois kilos de
riz qu'on nous donne ce n'est pas
suffisant pour manger du 1er au 30 de
chaque mois pour un mois entier ce n'est
pas assez seulement trois kilos de riz
pour manger 30 jours c'est de la folie
pour une seule personne
c'est de la folie ce mois-ci rose marie
et sa famille n'ont pas encore épuisé
leur quota deux directions la bodega du
quartier une épicerie géré par l'état
vous avez pris combien 2 le quota pour
une famille c'est à dire c'est combien
par personne 4 5 5 e par personne et par
mois par mois seulement oui c'est tout
avec le rationnement rose marie a donc
le droit à seulement 5 e par mois un
tarif très bas
si tu en veux plus faut les payer plus
cher sur les étals des oeufs et des sacs
de riz
aucun légume pas de viande non plus et
dans toutes les épiceries d'état c'est
pareil vous avez de la viande
pas vraiment non
certains magasins semi-privé vendent
parfois du port en revanche il n'y a
jamais de boeuf et vous n'avez pas de
viande de boeuf non mais qu il me
demande si on a de la viande de boeuf vu
que j'allais en prison pourquoi vous en
avez pas parce que c'est interdit ici à
cuba nous voulons savoir pourquoi les
cubains ont-ils si peur de parler du
boeuf au sud de la havane à une heure de
route
un troupeau pâture
surveillé de près moi on paye pour les
garder sinon les gens ils les vols c'est
pour ça je fais très attention
ce gardien travail pour un particulier
qui possède une dizaine de vaches
le propriétaire n'a aucun droit sur son
troupeau pas même de tuer ses bêtes
un tube âge qu'est ce qui se passe là
c'est un délit c'est comme si quelqu'un
vient chez toi pour te voler toute ta
maison c'est vraiment grave
c'est un délit très très grave c'est
pire que de tuer une personne oui bien
sûr c'est pire que tu es une personne
en clair le propriétaire doit simplement
élever ses vaches les garder en bonne
santé
puis le revendre à l'état après le
propriétaire l'avant à l'état il la vend
toute entière il n'a pas le droit de la
tuer ça marche comme ça si j'ai un
taureau par exemple un représentant de
l'état vient et me l'achète même site à
vaches se blesse tu es obligé de la
vendre à l'état le prix d'achat est fixé
arbitrairement par le régime
d'après nos informations l'état des
dommages de propriétaires des vaches
d'environ 10 pesos cubains le kilo soit
à peine 40 centimes d'euro
ensuite le régime commercialise la
viande dans ces boucheries de luxe elle
aussi contrôlée par l'état 20 fois plus
cher avec un slogan l'or rouge à 10
euros le kilo seuls les dignitaires de
l'êta les plus riches peuvent se
l'offrir
[Musique]
les touristes choyée par le régime ont
évidemment droit alors burger lors steak
et leurs brochettes dans les hôtels
contrôlées par l'état
dans le quartier de st augustine nous
retrouvons rose marie et son fils ismaël
tu as tout manger ils font partie des
oubliés du régime
elle ne se fait aucune illusion sur
l'ouverture ce qu'ils vont en tirer
profit ce sont les touristes américains
ils les dirigeants parce que les choses
ne vont pas changer à cuba pour avoir un
vrai changement il faudrait remplacer
les dirigeants et seulement après les
choses pourraient s'améliorer avec son
salaire de 13 dollars
rose-marie ne peut pas joindre les deux
bouts alors pour arrondir ses fins de
mois elle s'est lancée dans le trafic de
tabac 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
j'ai besoin de me débrouiller pour
élever mon enfant avec ce que fait
l'état ce n'est pas suffisant tout ce
que je peux lui acheter c'est une paire
de claquettes et un slip
parce que tout est très cher sur le
marché noir rose marie van ces
cigarettes 30% moins cher que les
magasins d'état et les clients viennent
se fournir directement chez elle sa
lutte à des cigarettes les cigarettes de
rosemary proviennent d'un magasin à prix
cassés et réservé aux militaires une de
ses connaissances détournent pour elle
la marchandise
tu avais une ou 2 2 elles cachent les
paquets un peu partout
il y en a dans la machine à laver ah non
ils sont dans l'autre cachette et même
dans la poubelle
rose marie est constamment sur ses
gardes si le voisin envoyé pour m e
dénoncé c'est pour ça que je les cache
si elle est prise en flagrant délit elle
risque une amende de 60 dollars quatre
fois son salaire d'institutrice merci
enfin à des pantalons
non j'en ai pas en ce moment mais dès
que j'en ai je te préviens je t'appelle
c'est quoi ta taille 34 voire ok 34 daz
vous le vendez des vêtements aussi oui
je vends tout ce que je peux si tu me
laisses ta caméra je la vends aussi
malgré le risque qu'elle prend son petit
business ne lui rapporte pas grand chose
tu vois aujourd'hui j'ai vendu trois
paquets et regarde ce que j'ai gagné dix
pesos cubains
il me reste encore quatre paquets à
vendre
car dix pesos c'est l'équivalent de 40
centimes d'euro mais rose marie à
trouver une autre activité
plus lucratives
[Musique]
nous sommes vendredi soir après une
semaine de travail avec les enfants elle
décompresse et se prépare pour aller
danser mais ce n'est pas tout à fait une
sortie comme les autres j'ai un peu
honte de vous en parler je vais sortir
pour voir si je rencontre un étrange est
quelqu'un qui n'est pas de ce pays
qu'ils puissent mêlée j'ai un enfant à
élever ce qu'elle appelle pudiquement de
l'aide
c'est en fait de la prostitution pendant
la journée je travaille à l'école disons
que le soir je me transforme une fois
par semaine elle porte une tenue sexy
pour tenter de rencontrer des touristes
fortunés
ce sont des clients d'un soir on se
rencontre et le lendemain on ne se
connaît pas la plupart sont des
espagnols et des français aussi il ya
beaucoup de français à cuba la
prostitution est pourtant interdite
rose-marie risque jusqu'à quatre ans de
prison elle s'expose aussi aux abus de
la police
il y a beaucoup de flics corrompus si
dans la soirée je fais 40 dollars et que
je tombe sur un flic il va vouloir m'en
prendre 30 et il ne me restera que 10
dollars pour la maison ce n'est pas
suffisant malgré l'interdiction sur
l'île communiste
environ vingt mille personnes se
prostituent à ta mère est au courant
plus ou moins
elle pense que je vais sortir avec des
amis mais elle sans doute maman regarde
rose marie tente tout de même de
protéger son fils ismaël retourne dans
ta chambre
[Musique]
direction le quartier du vedado
l'un des plus riches de la capitale elle
se rend dans une boîte de nuit à la mode
très prisée des touristes
c'est l'une des plus grandes de la
havane en quelques minutes à peine
elle se fait aborder par un touriste
italien rose marie va gagner cette nuit
80 dollars c'est à dire six fois son
salaire mensuel d'institutrice à cuba
comme rosemary l'institutrice 80% de la
population et fonctionnaires et vit avec
des salaires de misère
un retraité est payé un peu moins de 10
dollars par mois
un ouvrier vit avec 14 et un policier
les yeux les oreilles du régime souvent
en poche à peine plus de 50 dollars
alors pour survivre les 11 millions de
cubains sont devenus les champions du
monde de la débrouille
[Musique]
il y a ceux qui récupèrent des matériaux
divers et variés pour les revendre ceux
qui s'improvisent livreur ceux qui
réparent les vieilles berline avec les
moyens du bord mais à la havane
il ya aussi quelques malins qui ont
trouvé un nouveau filon ils profitent de
l'ouverture de cuba sur le monde pour
exercer une petite activité illégale tu
m'entends
en juillet dernier et ex à la compagnie
l'état qui détient le monopole des
télécommunications a installé 35 bornes
wifi internet
une petite révolution sur l'île même si
certains sites sont censurés les cubains
découvre les réseaux sociaux et
communiquent avec leur famille en exil
vous parlez avec mathier elle habite ou
aux états unis
petit problème tout de même le prix fixé
par l'état est littéralement prohibitif
pour se connecter une heure à peine
il faut débourser 2 dollars soit 10% du
salaire moyen
alors quelques génies ont flairé le bon
filon ils revendent illégalement l'accès
à internet à moitié prix nous les films
ont en caméra discrète
bonjour j'aimerais me connecter à
internet
ok venait
mais il va falloir patienter 15 minutes
pourquoi faut-il attendre parce que je
ne peux connectés qu'un certain nombre
de personnes à la fois par exemple quand
la connexion est mauvaise je peut
connecter uniquement huit personnes
sigean connect neuf on perd la connexion
mais quand elle est bonne on peut aller
jusqu'à 12
le principe est simple
oscar et son collègue chino achète une
carte prépayée et se connecte sur
internet
ensuite grâce à leur ordinateur ils
partagent la connexion avec plusieurs
clients nous avons fait le test
combien ça coûte 1 dollar 1 dollar pour
une heure de connexion
c'est donc la moitié du prix officiel de
la motte au téléphone
el chino connect notre téléphone à son
réseau ça y est je suis connecté
leur petit business fonctionne très bien
oscar et le ccino passent leurs journées
ici pour charger leurs ordinateurs
portables
c'est le système d ils ont improvisé un
branchement sauvage au réseau électrique
officiel ce n'est pas dangereuse que
vous faites c'est bien sûr que c'est
dangereux
je peux mais l'ecc trop cuts et il
faudra prendre des risques si je prends
pas le risque de mes lectures qts ramène
pas d'argent à la maison après une
longue négociation el chino a accepté de
nous en dire un peu plus sur ses
conditions de vie à cuba
[Musique]
il habite à 200 mètres à peine du
malecon la façade touristique de la
ville que l'état à rénova grand frêne
mais dans son quartier une rue plus loin
à peine tout tombe en ruine
même son immeuble
[Musique]
el chino est propriétaire de
l'appartement qu'il partage avec sa
femme sa fille et le reste de sa famille
en tout ils sont dix à habiter sous le
même toit ou est-ce qu'il est tombé
tonton qu'est ce qui lui est arrivé on
va leur montrer à l'entrée de
l'appartement le plancher a cédé à cause
de l'humidité laissant un trou béant
il y a une semaine à peine un drame
s'est produit ici c'est par ce trou que
moments clés tombée ils se cassaient six
côtes s'est perforé un poumon et s'est
cassé la clavicule et s'est cassé le
bras la tête
il est toujours en soins intensifs
aujourd'hui el chino craint pour la vie
de sa petite fille tiens prends la
petite se troue n'est pas le seul danger
de la maison dans l'une des toilettes
le plafond s'est effondré qu'est ce que
c'est que ça une pierre qui est tombé du
coup en là haut je les garde en souvenir
du coup el chino et sa famille n'arrive
plus à dormir je me couche tous les
soirs sans savoir si je vais me
réveiller parce que j'ai peur que la
maison s'effondre sur nous venez je vais
vous montrer à quoi ressemble notre
chambre dans la maison aucune intimité
avec sa femme et sa fille el chino
partagent une petite chambre de 6 mètres
carrés rongés par l'humidité
regardez à quoi ressemble le plafond a
fait attention aux autres
il laisse passer tout l'eau quand il
pleut je suis obligé de mettre ses
casseroles à des endroits bien précis et
elles font un petit concert quand les
casseroles sont pleines on les vide par
la fenêtre et on les remet en place
la maison a été déclaré insalubre par
l'état mais el chino et sa famille ne
peuvent aller nulle part ailleurs
l'état devrait nous aider à réparer la
maison car pour la rénover nous avons
besoin d'argent
parfois j'ai honte de faire venir des
abysses je n'aimerais pas qu'il voit les
conditions dans lesquelles je vis en
plus ils ont peur que le plafond leur
tombe sur la tête
à la havane comme dans le reste de l'île
soixante pour cent des habitations sont
en piteux état
tous les ans plusieurs dizaines de
bâtiments s'effondrent le pays compte un
déficit de plus de 700 mille logements
[Musique]
même si cuba joue la carte de
l'ouverture la liberté d'expression
n'est pas encore à l'ordre du jour sur
l'île il n'y a qu'un seul grand
quotidien g a contrôlé par le régime
le pays reste un état policier et la
havane est quadrillée sans relâche par
les forces de l'ordre
la propagande est partout et les
citoyens sont sous haute surveillance
[Musique]
malgré tout des cubains courage résiste
gorki aguila est liée à villars son
musicien
ils font partie d'une nouvelle
génération d'artistes militants ils
n'ont pas peur d'affirmer que
l'ouverture n'est qu'une illusion
nos gouvernants sont comme des empereurs
ce sont des rois en fait ici nous avons
une monarchie nous avons toute une
famille
les castro qui sont intouchables car ils
sont sacrés s'il y a un ego requis sont
en colère elle exprime c'est parce qu'un
de leurs amis un graffeur croupit en
prison depuis dix mois
ses pochoirs danilo les a faits le jour
on l'a rencontré il a peint son visage
et ce petit coq puis l'a marqué
réveillez vous danilo veut dire aux
cubains seller de réagir parce que tout
le monde est comme un zombie à cuba
alors réveillez vous
danilo maldonado est un célèbre graffeur
cubain son surnom el sexto il est
reconnu à l'étranger
il a exposé aux pays bas et aux etats
unis à cuba
il n'hésite pas à provoquer le régime si
on plie les bords du flyer on aura un
petit avion pour partir du pays
il ya un très joli mot qui se forment
qu'est ce qu'on peut lire liberté
mais comme à cuba il n'y a pas beaucoup
de liberté l'avion ne va pas très loin
mais lors d'une de ses dernières
performances artistiques
il a semble-t-il franchi la ligne rouge
fin 2014
danilo pas les prénoms fidel et raul sur
deux cochons qu'ils comptent relâché en
plein centre ville de la havane
mise au courant de son projet artistique
la police politique l'art est avant même
qu'il ait pu libérer les ports accusé d'
outrage
il est incarcéré sans procès il est
devenu un prisonnier politique
arroyo arena dans la banlieue de la
havane
maria victoria n'a presque plus de
nouvelles de son fils depuis dix mois
il y a quelques jours pourtant grâce à
des complicités internes
danilo a réussi à lui faire parvenir ce
petit cahier de dessin il y raconte
simplement ces dures conditions de
détention ils racontent qu'ils ont passé
deux jours sans eau que tout était très
sale que les toilettes étaient dans un
état pitoyable
alors tous les prisonniers ont commencé
à crier de l'eau de l'eau à ce moment-là
il on veut passer un bidon d'eau pour
les officiers mais rien pour les détenus
un épisode qui lui a inspiré ce dessin
pour protester contre cette détention
arbitraire danilo a entamé une grève de
la faim
maria victoria est très inquiète pour sa
vie une grève de la faim c'est quelque
chose de dangereux
il a des problèmes de tension et si on
le retrouve mort un matin on ne sera
jamais ce qui lui est arrivé et ça me
fait mal très mal mais je ne peux pas
continuer à pleurer
il faut que je me dise que mon fils va
sortir de prison
il faut qu'ils sortent libre pour tenter
d'accélérer sa libération les amis de
danilo l'ia et gore qui font tout pour
médiatiser la faire
ils viennent de lancer une grande
campagne de sensibilisation
internationale
[Musique]
ils ont enregistré un clip en soutien à
leur ami
il est diffusé partout à l'étranger sur
internet mais bloqué par la censure
cubaine
[Musique]
ils ont également à imprimer des
tee-shirts à son effigie exigent sa
libération
[Musique]
quelques jours plus tard la campagne de
pression médiatique semble avoir porté
ses fruits même s'il y a préfère rester
prudente
[Musique]
les agents de la sécurité d'état nous
ont dit que danilo seraient libérés
aujourd'hui je n'y crois pas trop car je
sais bien qu'il ment tout le temps
qu'ils n'ont pas de paroles mais la
famille de dany lo a beaucoup d'espoir
alors j'y vais pour la soutenir
moralement
l'ia retrouve son ami igor qui direction
la prison de vale green day dans la
banlieue de la havane
c'est ici que sont incarcérés les
personnes en attente de jugement
nous filmons discrètement ici la
surpopulation carcérale est
impressionnante
parfois les prisonniers sont obligés de
dormir par terre pire encore plus de
1500 détenus vivent entassés les uns sur
les autres
lors d'une précédente visite
lee avait réussi à glisser une caméra
danilo pour plus de discrétion il l'a
caché à l'intérieur d'un paquet de
cigarettes dans son dortoir
les lits superposés à trois étages
accueille plus de 200 prisonniers
les détenus n'ont droit qu'à 20 minutes
de sortie par jour dans la cour
[Musique]
lié à egor qui eux sont interdits de
visite la deuxième fois qu'on a essayé
de venir danilo nous avait inscrit sur
son carnet de visite mais nous non été
barrée le mien et celui de gorki
nous sommes parvenus à nous procurer ce
carnet de visite
on y voit clairement en effet que les
noms de l'ia et de gorki sont barrées il
porte même la mention crcr comme contre
révolutionnaires à l'entrée de la prison
la famille de danilo vient tout juste
d'arriver à porter le t-shirt
bien sûr ce sac à dos est rempli de
tee-shirts mais au bout de quatre heures
d'attentes sa mère commence à désespérer
c'est la deuxième fois qu'on nous dit
qu'ils vont le libérer mais on attend
toujours
dans ce pays il n'y a pas de justice
dans ce pays tout est mensonge
maria victoria parvient enfin à parler
au directeur de la prison
et là c'est la douche froide ils m'ont
dit que dans quinze jours ils vont le
libérer encore quinze jours
ouais il dit que danilo sera à la maison
prochainement
allons-y de toute façon ils vont pas
libéré aujourd'hui
[Musique]
imaginez vous comment je me sens déjà
j'avais pas beaucoup d'espoir mais je
peux pas rentrer avec un fusil pour le
faire sortir je dois continuer à
attendre
maria victoria et les amis de dany lo ne
compte pas relâcher la pression sur les
autorités cubaines comme danilo ils
seraient une cinquantaine de prisonniers
politiques à être enfermés dans les
geôles cubaines parfois s'opposer au
régime peut coûter encore plus cher
certains dissidents auraient payé cet
engagement de leur vie il y a trois ans
des hommes de main du gouvernement s'en
sont pris à cet homme oswaldo paya
fondateur de l'un des deux principaux
partis d'opposition le mouvement
chrétien de libération en juillet 2012
le dissident décède mystérieusement dans
un accident de voiture
d'après la télévision cubaine il
s'agirait d'une banale sortie de route
dans mon lectorat nous allons maintenant
lire un communiqué du ministère de
l'intérieur une voiture hyundai accent
tu es sorti de la route et a heurté un
arbre
la scène s'est déroulée sur l'autoroute
qui relie las tunas à bayamon dont cet
accident regrettable sont morts les
citoyens oswaldo jose paya 110 niasse et
harold cpdo escalade escalade
avant sa mort oswaldo paya dénoncer
ouvertement la dictature comme dans
cette interview pour enquête exclusive
enregistré un mois seulement avant son
accident mortel
et cambio qu'est ce qui a changé selon
vous ces dernières années à cuba il ya
eu des changements mais il n'y a pas eu
de progrès significatifs en termes de
démocratie pour nous c'est un faux
changement parce que c'est un changement
qui s'opère sans le peuple
un changement sans droits un changement
qui vise juste à consolider le pouvoir
d'une oligarchie militaire qui a tous
les droits
tous les privilèges la mort de l dopa ya
serait en fait un assassinat politique
maquillé en accident
son frère carlos est réfugié à madrid
d'après lui osvaldo et est régulièrement
menacée par la sécurité d'état
il suivait osvaldo tous les jours tous
les jours de sa vie
deux mois avant l'accident quelqu'un
avait foncé dans sa voiture et il avait
failli mourir
il ya quelques années ils avaient
déboulonné les roues de sa voiture
toute la famille allait monter dans le
véhicule mais heureusement un voisin les
a prévenus sinon ils seraient tous morts
mais les autorités cubaines confirme
qu'oswald bahia est mort dans un simple
accident de la route à 700 km à l'est de
la havane
le chauffeur est un homme politique
espagnol venu lui rendre visite
ayant survécu il avoue à la télévision
nationale cubaine être seul responsable
de l'accident
la dernière fois que j'ai regardé le
compteur je roulais à 80 km/heure
mais lorsque l'accident s'est produit je
n'ai pas regardé l'indicateur de vitesse
alors je ne peux pas dire exactement à
quelle vitesse je roulais j'ai perdu le
contrôle car il y avait des graviers et
je ne me rappelle de rien d'autre
rosa maria la fille d'ozzy valdo exil
elle aussi en espagne n'a jamais cru à
l'hypothèse de l'accident
a madrid quelques mois plus tard elle
retrouve angel cano méreau l'homme qui
conduisait la voiture va très bien angel
affirme aujourd'hui que ses aveux filmés
lui ont été extorqués au moment
d'enregistrer cette vidéo
ils ne m'ont pas laissé le choix je suis
dans un cachot à bayamon
alors soit je faisais la vidéo soit ma
situation et ce qui est vraiment
d'empirer il pouvait me tuer dire que
j'ai eu un infarctus ou qu'il ya une
bagarre avec un autre prisonnier alors
et on t'as demandé d'enregistrer cette
vidéo en disant que tu roulais à 80 100
km/heure 90 ans j'ai fait plusieurs
versions à la fin je lisais ce qu ils
m'écrivaient pour faire cette vidéo il a
fallu faire beaucoup de prises la preuve
c'est que comme je n'avais pas de moyens
pour contacter l'extérieur je boutonnet
et déboutonnée mon paulo pour montrer
que c'était des prises différentes angel
est formel la vitesse n'a rien à voir
avec l'accident
selon lui leur voiture a été
volontairement percuté par un autre
véhicule
c'est un nous étions suivis par trois
véhicules
d'abord c'était une voiture de la police
puis une lada rouge que nous avons semé
et enfin une voiture bleue plus moderne
c'est celle qui nous a percutés
la nation attend
[Musique]
malgré la mort de ce vélo sa famille
continue de faire l'objet
d'intimidations encore aujourd'hui nous
recevons des menaces de mort même si mon
père est décédé il ya trois jours
quelqu'un a téléphoné à la maison de ma
grand tante en lui disant on va te tuer
rosa maria a décidé de poursuivre le
combat de son père pour tenter de faire
progresser la démocratie sur l'île
communiste de cuba
[Musique]
retour à laval dans le quartier d'arroyo
arena chez maria victoria la mère de
l'artiste emprisonnés ces jours de fête
son fils dany lo vient tout juste d'être
libéré
quel bonheur
maria victoria n'en revient toujours pas
quel dommage que vous ne soyez pas dans
le coin pour le voir mon fils est très
maigre mais je suis si contente ses
grands-parents sont particulièrement ému
il pensait ne jamais le revoir
[Musique]
je ne pensais vraiment pas qu'ils le
laissent ressortir en vie hier soir je
me suis couché en pensant qu'ils
allaient le libérer ou le tuer je
n'arrêtais pas d'y penser
le premier coup de fil de danilo et pour
ses amis qui ont oeuvré à sa libération
en partant j'ai signé tous les documents
où l'on disait que j'étais libéré sans
aucune charge n'a et puis ils m'ont
ramené à la maison
gorki l'un de ses soutiens arrive enfin
chez danilo tu es en forme mon frère et
en une seule pièce tu as même un peu de
graisse
danilo a pourtant perdu ses skis l'eau
pendant ces dix derniers mois passés en
prison
regardez ouvre une boîte de sardines
sa mère lui a prévu un repas de fête
[Musique]
il adore le poisson alors je lui avais
gardé une boîte de sardines pour le jour
de sa libération
il est comment ce premier repas je n'ai
pas assez de mots pour vous expliquer
j'y crois même pas là j'entends la
musique que j'aime ma famille est à côté
de moi je me réveille d'un cauchemar
danilo exulte il a vécu l'enfer
[Musique]
pourtant à peine deux jours plus tard il
va prendre un nouveau risque
nous le retrouvons au côté des dames
âgées blanco l'association des femmes
qui militent pour la libération des
prisonniers politiques
ces dames en blanc épouses ou parents de
dissidents emprisonnés pose fièrement à
côté de lui en faisant la lettre elle le
signe de la liberté
danilo est venu leur apporter son
soutien et il est accueilli en héros à
maria cristina comment ça va mon ami je
suis si contente
et surtout que la lutte continue et
qu'ils essaient de les arrêter mais la
police est dans les parages
depuis six mois les forces de l'ordre
harcèlent les damas des blind quand ils
attendent pas loin d'ici pour nous
réprimer
d'habitude la police les embarquent
fouilles leurs affaires et les frappent
notre petite caméra attire l'attention
un agent en civil de la sécurité d'état
nous prend à part ce n'est pas dans
notre intérêt ni dans celui du
gouvernement de faire de la publicité à
ces femmes c'est un groupe financé par
l'étranger pour nous ce sont des
mercenaires
alors ce que vous faites est illégal ok
et vous voulez qu'on parte
oui vous devriez partir
un journaliste cubain présents sur place
nous conseille de prendre
l'avertissement très au sérieux
il vaut mieux partir
le risque c'est qu'ils effacent les
images de vos caméras voilà à quoi
ressemble ouverture à cuba a plus tard
on sait pas si le régime ne veut pas
qu'un média étranger film ce genre de
manifestation c'est parce que chaque
week-end ses opposants sont arrêtés
quelques semaines plus tôt une caméra a
réussi à saisir une scène de répression
[Musique]
la police attend les damas de blanco à
un carrefour
les forces de l'ordre encerclent le
cortège est filmé les manifestants qui
lancent leurs cris de résistances une
foule de contre-manifestants recruté par
l'état arrive sur leurs pancartes on
peut lire damase et blanco dégager de
mon parc
[Musique]
mais
les esprits s'échauffent
[Musique]
la police intervient chaque week-end
plusieurs dizaines de damas des blancos
sont arrêtés et placés en garde à vue le
régime mène contre elle une guerre
d'usure
si la havane par air devenir
fréquentable
les militaires qui contrôlent le pouvoir
ne semblent pas encore prêts à desserrer
l'étau de la répression il profite de
l'ouverture et des touristes pour se
remplir les poches pendant que la grande
majorité des cubains eux n'en tire aucun
profit
[Musique]